i'm here with one of the stars of shark
tank barbara corcoran
i mean shark tank is one of your many
credits on your cv and also joining us
today is a ceo who started her million
dollar lifestyle brand on etsy oh my
favorite place in the world please
welcome grace elea
hi grace hello
i'm doing so well i'm doing so well
thanks so much for having me
well you built your brand with ten
thousand dollars
how did you do it
yeah so i started we started the
business in 2014 i had been the idea
itself came about a year earlier because
i was on vacation visiting my family in
kenya
and i all the hair on the back of my
head had broken off unfortunately and i
if it could have been alleviated had i
just been wearing a scarf and so that's
where the idea started turning that
there has to be something out there that
is stylish enough to feel cute when
you're on vacation but also still
protective of the hair and so a year
later i made the first prototype in
february of 2014
and from there in may or so my brother i
was telling my brother about the idea
and he basically offered me a
uh ten thousand dollar credit card he
was like here's a credit card for 10
with ten thousand dollars on it let's
see what you can do with this and with
that i made my first manufacturing run i
i created our first website and we built
all of our content
and in september of 2014 we launched the
business oh wow
all right well we have a small business
owner from columbus ohio who calls
herself a
mompreneur which is the cutest thing
ever and she's eager to ask for advice
on her growing business take a look
hi my name is jennifer sanger and i
started jamison and bexley jamison and
bexley was started to provide
adventurous clothes for adventurous kids
it started in september 2017. i knew i
wanted to start this business and i
wanted to name it after my son and his
big sister bexley i wanted to provide
clothing that kept my kids looking like
kids and offered different types of
clothing for gender neutral options as
well
my husband and my kids are super
supportive if you ask my daughter bexley
this is her company and i just work for
her and my son is the best little
salesman ever at my pop-up shop my
company created the mixed club t-shirt
to show my kids that even though they
are multi-race they're not loved and
blessed and they are mixed with well
being a mompreneur is everything it's
being able to watch my kids grow being
able to let them see me grow a business
my business over the past year
kind of skyrocketed i left corporate
america right when our state shut down
to covet and i was able to put 110 into
my side hustle which is now my main
hustle i'm strictly online but my hope
fingers crossed is to have a physical
retail storefront one day and to be
everywhere in the u.s and even
international i've always wanted to be
in fashion my whole entire life so to
make my dream as a little girl come true
is to show my kids that hey mommy can do
it so can i
please welcome
[Applause]
jennifer what is your business need and
what's your ultimate goal okay so first
off drew you are my best friend in my
head oh my god i'm actually your best
friend in reality like yes since high
school like everyone's going to be like
oh my gosh
jen is like on drew barrymore i'm like
yeah he's looking at me now so yes and
barbara you are my favorite shark you've
got good taste yes
yes
i watch the show for fun but no like i
need help i would love to hear from
barbara
what is your advice what are your
feelings uh about brick and mortar also
well specific to you i don't like the
idea i hope you don't mind me telling
you what i think really right no i my
husband will agree with you so he's
gonna be like i told you so
we don't want to give that guy the
status absolutely not
but uh let me share my thinking with you
i could vis envision you in a design
studio where your manufacturing and
visitors are coming in at the same time
there's something very exciting to see
how things are done and to get to talk
with the entrepreneur not as wanting to
sell them something but bring their kids
in take tours and then you accomplish
two things at once what i don't like
about retail is you have to really ramp
up your production get a lot of quantity
going and it's guesswork you don't
really know the rents are outrageous on
retail and you have to sign a long-term
lease and it's hard to anticipate
whether your company will outgrow it
when they'll outgrow it or whether they
won't measure up to it i try to pop up
shop it's so hard i mean
and everything has really moved to
online um so maybe at least at first
focus there but i'd like to ask grace
what her thoughts are
on this because she's actually doing it
yeah no i actually completely agree with
what barbara and drew have just said you
know we live in a really special time
where
beforehand we used to have to find our
way into small rooms
filled with people who make really big
decisions for national brands right and
now
we can go directly to the consumer so i
actually my advice is to go directly to
the consumer continue selling online and
sell that way as opposed to getting it
like barbara was saying a 10-year lease
that you have to you know uh keeper but
again i don't want to step on any dreams
i've you know if that's what you want to
do
um but i think i think there is a little
bit of a pivot that you could do
do there in order to grow grow
exponentially really big we went from
the 10 000 credit card to selling over a
million products to
over 500 000 people
because we sold online primarily at
first before getting into retail now
grace would you invest in jameson and
bexley is this a company that makes
sense to you
definitely so jameson and bexley you it
sounds like jen you are in the position
that we were in when i was
basically running most of the the
operation with my family out of my
parents back room and so what i'd like
to do
is invest 20 000 right now in your
business
[Applause]
you're doing amazing things
[Laughter]
the fact that you've created a
product that people are buying right now
already it's such an amazing feat you
know that you could create something
that people want to purchase is already
an amazing feat so i'm happy to
to invest in your in your dream oh my
god thank you so much and that's not all
everyone in the audience is gonna go
home with a hundred and fifty dollar
gift card redeemable on
[Applause]
gracealeah.com more
[Applause]
um jennifer singer i believe in you
grace elea thank you for your generosity
thank you as well as thank you so much
your opportunities that you're giving
and barbara what i'm afraid i
i just think the world of you and i'm so
glad to finally be in person with you
and be able to show you that love and
scare you slightly this is such an honor
and a thrill i love it i love you i love
it
thank you so much
shark tank season 13 airs friday on abc
at 8 pm eastern 7 pm central or you can
be like me and binge it on the couch for
hours on their marathons we'll be right
back
[Music]